Un dragón de de tierra y piedra
de casi 21 000 km
serpentea a través de la campiña de China
con una historia casi tan larga y
serpenteante como su estructura.
La Gran Muralla comenzó siendo
varios muros de tierra apisonada
construido por los estados feudales
individuales durante el período Chunqiu
como protección contra los invasores
nómadas del norte de China y entre sí.
Cuando el emperador Qin Shi Huang
unificó los estados en el año 221 a.C.,
la meseta del Tíbet y el Océano Pacífico
se convirtieron en barreras naturales,
pero las montañas en el norte
seguían siendo vulnerables
a invasiones mongolas, turcas
y de los xiongnu.
Para defenderse de ellos,
el emperador amplió los muros
construidos por sus predecesores,
conectando alguno
y fortaleciendo otros.
Así las estructuras crecieron
de Lintao en el oeste
a Liaodong en el este,
que colectivamente se conocían
como La Muralla Larga.
Para realizar esta tarea,
el emperador reclutó soldados y plebeyos,
no siempre voluntariamente.
De los cientos de miles de constructores
registrados durante la dinastía Qin,
muchos campesinos
fueron reclutados por la fuerza
y otros eran criminales que
cumplían sentencias.
Bajo la dinastía Han,
la muralla se hizo aún más larga,
llegando a los casi 6000 km,
abarcarcando desde Dunhuang
hasta el Mar de Bohai.
El trabajo forzado continuó
bajo el emperador Han Xuandi,
y la reputación de la muralla se convirtió
en un lugar notorio de sufrimiento.
Poemas y leyendas de la época
hablaban de obreros sepultados
en fosas comunes cercanas,
o incluso dentro de la propia muralla.
Y si bien no hay restos humanos
encontrados en el interior,
las fosas nos indican que
muchos trabajadores murieron
por accidentes, hambre y agotamiento.
La muralla era formidable,
pero no invencible.
Tanto Genghis y su hijo Khublai Khan
lograron superar la muralla
durante la invasión de los mongoles
en el siglo XIII.
Después de que la dinastía Ming
ganara el control en 1368,
comenzaron a refortificar y
consolidar aún más la muralla
utilizando ladrillos y piedras
de los hornos locales.
Un promedio de 7 m de alto
y 6.4 de ancho,
las paredes de casi 9000 km fueron
puntuadas por torres de vigilancia.
Cuando se avistaban asaltantes,
señales de fuego y humo
eran intercambiadas entre torres
hasta que llegaban los refuerzos.
Las aberturas en la muralla permitían
a los arqueros disparar contra los invasores,
mientras que los más grandes se utilizan
para colocar piedras y mucho más.
Pero incluso esta nueva muralla
no era suficiente.
En 1644, los clanes Manchu del norte
derrocaron a la dinastía Ming
para establecer la dinastía Qing,
anexionándose Mongolia, también.
Por ello, para esta segunda vez,
China era gobernada por la misma gente
que había intentado impedir la invasión.
Con las fronteras del imperio ampliadas
ahora más allá de la Gran Muralla,
las fortificaciones
perdieron su propósito.
Y sin refuerzo regular, la muralla
empezó a estar en mal estado,
tierra apisonada erosionada,
y los ladrillos y la piedra fueron
saqueados como material de construcción.
Pero su trabajo no había terminado.
Durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
China utilizó secciones como
defensa contra la invasión japonesa,
y se dice que algunas partes se siguen
utilizando para el entrenamiento militar.
Pero el propósito principal actual
de la Muralla es cultural.
Por ser una de las mayores estructuras
hechas por el hombre en la Tierra,
se le concedió en 1987 el grado
de Patrimonio de la Humanidad
Originalmente construido para
mantener a la gente fuera de China,
la Gran Muralla ahora da la bienvenida
a millones de visitantes cada año.
De hecho, la afluencia de turistas
ha causado que se deteriore la muralla,
lo que llevó al gobierno chino a mover
iniciativas de conservación.
También se ensalza como única estructura
visible por el hombre desde el espacio.
Por desgracia, eso no es del todo cierto.
En la órbita baja de la Tierra,
todo tipo de estructuras,
como puentes, carreteras
y aeropuertos son visibles,
y la Gran Muralla apenas es perceptible.
Desde la Luna, no tiene
ninguna oportunidad.
pero es desde la Tierra que
debemos seguir estudiandola
pues las nuevas secciones todavía
se descubren cada pocos años,
ramificándose
desde el cuerpo principal
y ampliando este extraordinario
monumento al logro humano.